nitro is back on team liquid and he had
a lot to say about his time in valorant
as well as his decision to return to
counter-strike so today we're coming at
you with a quick and juicy one about the
biggest player to ever return from the
valorant hinterlands at least so far
[Music]
grand slam winner legendary n a igl team
liquid fan favorite there are a lot of
ways you can describe nitro but valorent
pro is no longer among them on sunday
team liquid announced that nitro had
returned to their counter-strike roster
but it was hardly a surprise back in
november upcomers george gettys reported
that nitro was thinking about his future
and considering return to counter-strike
now in an interview with team liquid's
austin ryan nitro confirmed that he
hadn't made any decision until december
but now that he has returned we've got a
lot to talk about first his time invalid
nitro joined hundred thieves alongside
team liquid alumnus hiko and they put up
some pretty good results they won first
strike n a which was the biggest
tournament for the region up until that
point they also placed first at a later
challengers qualifier they also played
one of the most exciting series in the
game to date and if you missed our video
on it in our every second count series
you should go check that out but
basically their accomplishments weren't
exactly jumping off the page they were a
solid team with a wealth of experience
in the genre but true dominance wasn't
ever really in the conversation
especially once international play
became more common in that liquid
interview nitro also mentioned that
there were a couple players where he had
to be a little bit more hands-on than he
was used to and that was sort of a sore
spot and it seems like it was the pgl
major that reminded him of his love for
the game that gave him his career but
the question is now
how is this new look liquid going to
perform as we saw with the previous
incarnations of team liquid csgo
appearances can be deceiving they were
one of the weakest teams in the early
online era stringing together basically
nothing but losses except for their
first place win at esl pro league season
11 finals which of course had just been
moved online then nitro left in august
2020 twists went to phase and grimm and
fallen were brought in as replacements
the team still looked excellent on paper
but that incarnation failed to win any
legitimately big events though they did
have some podium finishes here or there
and the scariest part about it is that
it seems like there's still no answer to
the question of
why from the liquid interview with nitro
quote we want a grand slam on land then
we go lose to a nobody team online so
it's like what the hell's going on
liquid i don't know dude there's no
solution it's just how we are it's hard
it really is then the fans look at you
and they're like why don't you just play
the same it's not how it works so can
this new liquid team do any better well
elysian naf are obviously very familiar
with nitro but with oc as their new oper
and cs legend shocks joining the squad
it really remains to be seen it seems
doubtful that nitro would ever have to
micromanage shocks who has a storied
career in the game and has even tried
igling in the past oc on the other hand
is a 22 year old oper who you may know
from extra salt and while he put up some
pretty great results there it remains to
be seen how he'll integrate into a
roster with players that are this
accomplished and experienced nitro said
in the interview that he thinks a team
has top five potential but that they
might need some work to get there that
seems fair to me but since the online
era began team liquid's rosters have
seemed better than they've actually
played and now with everything that's
happening consistent land play seems far
from certain but there's one last thing
i want to talk about unlike many people
who enjoy the constant back and forth of
valorent vs cs dimitri i actually enjoy
both games and i think that nitro's time
invalorant has actually made him a
better cs player sure he's not going to
be jet dashing around inferno although
that would be pretty awesome if he could
somehow do that but think about it with
me for a moment he had to lead a team
with new players some of whom were very
new to competition he had to flex onto
the op yet to think about this game in
its infancy and he had to lead this team
through a difficult time and mostly
online there are opportunities for
growth there maybe you don't think that
this liquid roster is an instant major
contender or maybe you do but i think
we're gonna see a hungrier nitra than we
did in summer 2020 and if you're a fan
of nacs
that's a sight for sore eyes
by the way every time you do a canadian
or american accent it absolutely
destroys me like i'm trying to place
your accent but it's actually
in 16 different places or something
right because it's like it's got too
many like borrowed things from it
and yeah
yeah that's so i'm sure when i do
british accents like people people
probably like who are actually from the
uk are probably like yo that's not
like there's no place where someone
where a single person speaks british
like that like you know like there's no
way
sweet okay